hey everyone
welcome to this video on population and
sample by simply learn
in this video we will introduce you to
the concept of population and sample
along with some real world examples of
where they should be used
so let's get started so what can you
expect from this video
what's in it for you first we will
answer the question
what is population then
we will explain the meaning of samples
to you
we will look at some differences between
population and samples by looking at
some common examples
followed by looking at how we can
collect data from a population
and from a sample
so what is the population
in statistics population is the entire
set of items from which data is drawn
for a statistical study
it can be a group of individuals a set
of items
etc it constitutes the data pool for a
study
in general a population is the entire
group that you want to draw conclusions
about
usually when we talk about population
you think about the people living in an
area at a time
but in research a population doesn't
always refer to people
it can mean a group containing elements
of anything you want to study such as
objects
events organizations countries
species organisms etc
for example all undergraduate students
in the netherlands
or say you would like to know whether
there is an association between job
performance and the amount of home
working hours per week in the specific
case of belgian data scientists in this
case
the population may be belgian data
scientists however
if the scope of the study is more narrow
then the population will be more
specific and include
only workers who meet that certain
criteria
the point is that the population should
only include people to whom the results
will apply
since in this case and many others it is
impossible to observe the entire
statistical population due time
constraints
constraints on geographical
accessibility and constraints on the
researchers
a researcher would instead absorb the
statistical
sample from the population in order to
attempt to learn something about the
population
as a whole
this brings us to the topic what is a
sample
a sample represents the group of
interest from the population
which we will use to represent our data
the sample is an unbiased set of the
population which best represents the
whole data
a sample consists of some observations
drawn from the population
so a part or a subset of the population
the sample is the group of elements who
actually participated in the study
the size of the sample is always less
than the total size of the population
typically the population is very large
making a census or a complete
enumeration of all values in the
population impractical
or impossible the sample represents a
subset of manageable size
samples are collected and statistics are
calculated from the sample so that one
can make
interferences or extrapolations from the
sample to the population
this process of collecting information
from a sample is referred to as sampling
say you are testing the effects of a new
fertilizer on crop yield
all the crop fields represent your
population whereas the 10 crop fields
you tested correspond to your sample
now let's look at the differences
between population and samples with the
help of some examples
the first example would be that all
students in a class
would constitute the population of that
class
a sample would be only the top 10
students within the same class
the sample is a small subset of the
population in this case
advertisements for it jobs in india
would mean
the complete search results that pops up
when you search
it jobs in india a sample of that would
be the top
50 advertisements for the same jobs
another example is all countries of the
world
this represents a population of all the
countries
a sample would be countries with
published data on birth rates and gdp
since 2000s
next let's look at how to collect data
from a population
data from a population is collected when
your research question needs a large
amount of data
or information about every member of the
population is available
populations are used when your research
question requires or when you have
access to data from
every member of the population usually
it's only straightforward to collect
data from a whole population when it is
small
accessible and cooperative population
data is used when the data pool is small
and cooperative to giving all of the
required data for larger populations we
can use sampling to represent part of
the population
it is hard to collect data from for
example
a high school administrator wants to
analyze the final exam scores of all
graduating seniors to see if there is a
trend
since there are only interested in
applying the findings to the graduating
seniors in this high school
they can use the whole population data
set
for larger and more dispersed
populations it is often difficult or
impossible to collect data from
every individual for example every 10
years
the federal u.s government aims to count
every person living in the country using
the u.s census
this data is used to distribute funding
across the nation
however historically marginalized and
low-income groups have been difficult to
contact
locate and encourage participation from
because of non-responses the population
count is incomplete and biased towards
some groups which results in
disproportionate fundings across the
country
in cases like this sampling can be used
to make more precise interferences about
the population
and for that we can collect data from a
sample
how do we go about collecting data from
a sample
samples are used when the population is
large in size
scattered or it's generally hard to
collect data on individual instances
within it we can use a small sample of
the population to make
overall hypotheses when your population
is too large in size
geographically dispersed or difficult to
contact
it is necessary to use a sample with
statistical analysis
you can use sample data to make
estimates or test hypotheses about
population data
for example you want to study political
attitudes
in young people your population is the
3000 undergrads in the netherlands
because this is not practical to collect
data from all of them
you use the sample of 300 undergraduate
volunteers
from three dutch universities this is
the group who will complete your online
study
ideally a sample should be randomly
selected and representative of the
population
using probability sampling methods such
as simple random sampling
or stratified sampling reduces the risk
of sampling bias
and enhances both internal and external
validity
and with that we come to the end of a
population and sample video
i hope you enjoyed this video do not
forget to like subscribe
and share this video and do click on the
bell icon to get notifications
every time simply learn releases a new
video thank you for watching
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here